foreign
[Music]
this is Monica Sun from janscript in
this webinar I'm going to talk about the
current methodologies and bottlenecks of
Western blotting and more importantly
how to accelerate Western blotting with
the Optimal Solutions while maintaining
industry standard quality
there are various research techniques in
the field of protein analysis and
Western blotting as one of the most
useful tools for protein detection and
Analysis
it has been widely applied in many
research topics such as biochemistry and
proteomics because of its gold standard
quality and essential role in
immunodection however a couple
challenges faced by many researchers out
there in the field include its
non-skippable sequential procedure from
loading and running samples transferring
to membranes blocking antibody
incubation and multiple washes this is
the universal procedure which takes
hours today status labor consuming and
time inefficient
and second it's inaccuracies and
inconsistency associated with all the
manual procedure which causes low
reproducibility in Theta and potential
waste of samples
with that being said how can we dissect
the challenges and resolve them in each
step as the project we all try to work
on Western blotting normally includes
these lab procedures gel electrophrases
child transfer blocking and incubation
and sometimes gel staining I will go
into details of each step to address the
challengers or common issues and how we
can select the Optimal Solutions to
achieve better and more consistent
results
tools or lab consumables related to gel
electrophrases is apparently the gels
both Precast or homemade gels this is
the step when denatured proteins are
loaded into gels and run intellectual
phrases to separate the protein bands by
molecular weight the common issues in
the protein separation step usually is
the smiley or smearing bands or
sometimes the homemade gels are too
fragile to handle with
gel selection can be optimized from
several technical perspectives including
the types and concentrations of
polyacrylamide which is the common
composition of Precast gels and Sample
preparation reagents
first of all by comparing two homemade
gels Precast gels have a more uniform
manufacturing process including control
on temperature oxygen level chemical
Purity and freshness and consistency of
the casting profile so I'll focus on
talking about selecting Precast gels in
this webinar
foreign
so what are the factors determine high
quality gel electrophoresis using the
Precast gels the Precast gels are mainly
polyacrylamide gels they are polymerized
by a mixture of acrylamide which are the
long polymers and bisacrylamide which
are the short cross-linkers when these
two types of polymers react they form
into this porous gel the pore size is
determined by the concentration of both
acrylamide and vesicular acrylamide also
there are other factors such as the
initiator and Catalyst and this
polymerization reaction but the most
important or influencing Factor here is
the concentration of acrylamide
different brands have different
concentrations which result in different
separation of Separation performance as
well
you want the proteins to migrate in
relatively fast speed in a larger pore
size gel but you also want stability and
band consistency so it's important to
have it balanced and that's how
janscript gels generate premium
separation results and a fast run based
stumbles of that
the second factor is the sample loading
buffer
before loading the protein samples we
usually heat samples with SDS and dtt to
denature the proteins and pH of the
common sample loading buffer will
decrease from 6.5 to about 4.5 upon
heating which could not completely break
the disulfide bonds in most proteins
transcript has a sample loading buffer
that its pH can still remain at seven
and thus helps with better protein
denaturation and separation
another two factors are both benefits of
the distress gels and it has higher
operating pH while running to increase
modification of the proteins
and neutral casting pH to avoid
hydrolysis and thus is more stable for
storage and has a longer shelf life
with those technical information being
shared I would like to introduce the
short page Precast distress gels
developed by genscript to separate a
light range of protein sizes by
electrophrases it can generate sharp and
consistent bands which is the most
important fast run times while
pertaining the good separation quality
room temperature storage supported
because supported by asbestris
composition so it's quite stable at room
temperature running buffer including
each pack and large loading volume
because of our special well design as a
Precast gel you can see how it generates
the bend consistency here High
sensitivity and clear and flat bands
that are not bent at the edge
to run gel electrophrases there are some
other consumables involved for optimal
and consistent results we also recommend
using the full set of solutions to make
the process easier for you gel tank is
the most essential tool which supports
for up to too many gels it's also
compatible with our traditional block
module for transfer
second the 4X LDS simple buffer is the
one I mentioned that has a higher pH for
more complete protein denaturation
mes and Mark's running buffer is the
buffer you pour into the gel tank for
fast run these two options can fulfill a
wide range of protein sizes
last but not least the protein ladders
these are the sharp and precise markers
for protein electrophrases the pre-stain
we have is the most popular one which
ranges from five kilodones to 270
kilodones and there's also unstained
ladder and Western block viewable
leather both help as a troubleshooting
reference along the western blotting
procedure
so after gel electrophrases jaw transfer
is the second procedure in Western
blotting related tools are automated
transfer systems or traditional wet
transfer the block module
most common issue in this step is the
difficulty in transferring large
proteins
in order to find the optimal solution
for this gel transfer procedure let's
first take a look at the comparison
chart between gold standard wet transfer
and automated fast transfer device
in this gel transfer technology
comparison slide I will compare the
three methodologies which are the
traditional manual web transfer block
module semi-dry or dry automated
transfer device
automated web transfer device
comparison will be made from five
aspects transfer time protein size
coverage transfer efficiency compared to
the the industry standard its benefits
and limitations
so first transfer time the traditional
wet transfer block module takes about
one hour to overnight the semi-dry
device on the market usually takes about
9 to 15 minutes and the automated wet
transfer device we have takes about 9 to
17 minutes
automated instruments definitely save
more time compared to the traditional
one
the traditional one because of its gold
standard wet transfer it can technically
transfer transfer full range of proteins
the larger the protein is the longer
transfer time it takes
the semi-dry device even though it's
very fast and convenient the size
coverage only ranges from about three
kilotones to 200 kilodones and it's
usually challenging to transfer larger
proteins
the automated wet transfer instrument
because it incorporates the wet transfer
technology it has a wider protein size
coverage from three kilodones to one fat
more than one thousand kilodones giving
more benefits to the researchers to
transfer large proteins
in terms of transfer efficiency since we
are comparing to the traditional
methodology as the gold standard
semi-dry is good for smaller proteins
only and automated by transfer has
comparatively good efficiency compared
to the industry standard
benefits of the traditional one is that
it's reliable and cost efficient but the
manual operation is messy and labor
consuming and sometimes has bubbles
hidden between the gels and membranes
which reduce the transfer performance
the semi-dry or dry devices on the
market they are fast and convenient for
sure has a clean setup generates
consistent results but limitations are
that it's an inefficient inefficiency to
transfer large proteins because it's not
wet transfer technology and its lack of
buffer to support the larger protein
transfer and also high cost on
consumables is another concern of many
lab researchers
for the automated wet transfer device it
has the benefits of Automation and fast
it has pre-packed reagent kit to ensure
convenience and consist consistency the
limitation however is that it requires
more bench space than the block module
and semi-dry devices
going back to the original question how
do we find the optimal solution from the
market for gel transfer now we know that
we have the traditional manual wet
transfer which has the gold standard
transfer efficiency and semi-dry or dry
transfer device that is fast and
convenient in operation guaranteed
result consistency but they each have
their own limitations janscript combines
the benefits of these two common methods
while eliminating the limitations to
invent e block L1 the automated wet
transfer system it has the high
reproducibility and efficiency of
traditional wet transfer with the speed
and convenience of semi dry transfer
systems
it's Unique and a clean transfer
sandwich setup design eliminates the
messy and redundant preparation and
cleaning processes this is also easy to
assemble using the dry sponges gel
membrane cassette according to the
instructions
a block L1 fast sweat transfer system
has simple and user-friendly design
including its user-friendly interface
which supports simple Hands-On operation
eblock can run two gels in separate
Chambers individually and even with
different transfer protocols that
fulfill your need for a wide range of
protein sizes
but this play shows separate running
status and times for each channel the
keypad supports easy operation and
buffer connecting parts on the side
allow for E for clean buffer and water
to be used for each cycle and automated
drainage of waste solution
the second feature is the automated fast
transfer the screenshot here shows only
17 minutes for a default standard
protocol for common protein sizes for
smaller than 30 kilodons we also have
short protocol which only takes about
nine minutes and for larger than 300
kilodon proteins we have a long protocol
which takes about 23 to 24 minutes
the entire process is automated and fast
and next we have the all-inclusive
consumable kits these are pre-packed
transfer kits compatible with e-blot
instruments the kit includes pre-cut
nitrocellulose or pbdf membranes and
concentrated transfer buffer everything
is prepared in the Box for you to start
using the e-block device
in addition to its unique design and
convenience eblot also maintains High
transfer efficiency for all size
proteins comparing to the traditional
wet transfer and semi-dry instruments
e-block has a higher transfer efficiency
before both small proteins on the bottom
row here and larger proteins on the top
row here
data on the right side also shows a
demonstration of using e-block to
transfer up to 1 200 kilodaltons
proteins in 24 minutes which is the long
protocol on e-block since a block keeps
the gold standard wet transfer
technology and its automated design
that's how it's able to support full
protein size coverage
after gel transfer I think this next
step blocking incubation and washing is
the step which gives most people
headaches it's the most tedious and
repetitive procedure in Western blotting
and consistent results are sometimes
inevitable as well and available tools
on the market are either the traditional
Shaker and manual operation or automated
membrane processing system
here you can see the common procedure of
the western blotting workflow from
blocking primary antibody incubation
three times washing secondary antibody
incubation and another three times
washing there's a lot back and forth
manual operation in this process and
takes hours to two days to finish the
whole process
if we replace all the manual work with a
fully automated membrane processing
device it can free you from a super Time
and Labor consuming process easy West
light is a bench top friendly device
about the same size as a Shaker that can
help you automate all these steps on the
left
it's completely hands off generate
consistent results it's programmable and
also antibody recoverable
easy West light is a fully automated
Western blotting device it has a
user-friendly touch screen that allows
protocol customization so any special or
unique protocol you have developed for
your samples or antibodies you can input
and save them in the program you can
also change and optimize as needed
we have the removable membrane cassette
which is for membrane loading so after
drug transfer when you have the protein
bands transferred to the membrane
already place the membrane inside the
cassette for blocking an incubation in
this device since the cassette is
removable you can also incubate it at
four degree for overnight in the easy
West program there's also an overnight
option for you to select one membrane
cassette can incubate two membranes at a
time
as I said easy West can do all the
blocking incubation and washing steps in
one operation and here's where you load
the reagents for one time antibodies are
also recoverable back to the original
reagent tubes here different from e-blot
that only are pre-packed consumable kits
are compatible and can be used for easy
West you can use your own region or
Solutions so you can prepare your own
solutions to be used to start using this
instrument
last but not least we also have a
compatible easy West stylune kit which
is a fast blocking reagent if you would
like an even more a more Speedy process
this fast blocking reagent shortens
incubation time and also skips the
blocking step as well the combination of
the easy West styling kit and the easy
West automated device the combination is
definitely more time efficient and
convenient
here's the data demonstration comparing
traditional milk blocking reagent on a
Shaker versus easy West with Dylon kit
combination you can see as you can see
the time used in each step adding up to
four hours for the traditional method
and only about one hour and 50 minutes
for easy West easy West also generates
if not better but similar results to the
traditional way so its automated design
is not compromising the gold standard
quality for our researchers
in addition to the common Western
blotting procedures some biochemistry
Labs also do a lot of gel staining there
are many staining reagents out there but
still messy operation and time consuming
are the common issues for this procedure
there's also one automated staining
system and I will go into the detailed
comparison on the next slide
in this section I will talk about the
comparisons among stain free system
silver staining fast Kumasi staining
reagent and automated clemency staining
device from five aspects as well I will
briefly go over the technical
description of each one very fast and
the stain-free system proteins are made
fluorescent and can be immediately
visualized in the gel containing a
tri-hello compound so the time needed
for visualization is very fast and
immediate its benefits include the
strong protein signals with low
background and immediate visualization
well the limitations are that it's only
able to react with tryptophan in
proteins and only able to visualize
those the tri-halo compound as well and
it's also not compatible with the
regular page gels so the tools needed
for this method is stain free gel in an
Imager
second the silver staining is when
silver ions interact and bind to the
proteins and deposit into the surface of
gel at the location of protein bands
which requires about hours to overnight
to visualize its greatest Advantage is
that it has nanogram level sensitivity
while it involves multiple manual steps
and very time consuming and requires
silver staining reagent for this method
the third method which I think is also
the most common method is the the fast
Kumasi staining reagent it's the gold
standard Kumasi blue staining of gels to
visualize protein bands which takes
about 20 minutes to overnight depending
on the sensitivity
it is gold standard technique and very
cost efficient but messy time consuming
and inconsistent results sometimes the
consumable needed is only the Kumasi
blue staining reagent
last is the automated komasi staining
device developed developed by janscript
it's an automated system integrates the
traditional three steps of fixing
staining and destaining into one to
simplify the process page gels can be
stained and destained within 10 minutes
using Kumasi blue reagent using this
device
its biggest Advantage is its automation
fast easy and clean setup and consistent
results limitation is that it requires
more bench top space compared to the
other three methods tools needed are the
automated device and Kumasi blue reagent
by looking at this comparison table it's
easier to see that the best substitute
of the gold standard staining method is
the automated device when it has better
staining results in a much faster time
it also doesn't limit to visualize the
proteins only based on reaction with the
tryptophan tryptophan bins So based on
that I would like to introduce more
about our automated Kumasi staining
device it's called e-stain
Eastern L1 fast staining system is the
only automated Kumasi blue staining
device on the market similar to e-blot
transfer system it can stain two gels at
the same time and also individually in
separate Chambers it's fully automated
and fast only takes about 10 minutes to
complete the full staining and
destaining process
it has the sandwich setup that is easy
to use and can be inserted into the
chamber it's clean and convenient with
pre-made Kumasi blue steamy solution in
addition to its automation fast and
convenience e-stain also generates
consistent results with the blue gel
staining with high sensitivity as low as
12.5 nanograms
for researchers that do membrane
staining e-stain can also support
membrane staining function with the
pencils s solution
here's more data showing comparison
between Eastern results and other common
methods easting generates better
sensitivity than both traditional manual
staining and stain-free system
this is a brief Showcase of how easy to
use and it cleans the e-stain setup is
the first step is to place a gel on the
e-stain gel holder which is compatible
to all kinds of mini gels second cover
the gel with a clean and wet filter
paper provided in the pre-made package
and insert the gel holder into the
chamber
and then start the automated program for
10 minutes staining and destaining and
after 10 minutes take out the gel holder
and check results this entire process
doesn't involve any Hands-On touch to
the stainy solution and make sure make
sure your lab environment is clean and
all of these can be completed in 10
minutes
to recap what I included in this webinar
we've always been struggling with the
traditional method traditional Western
blotting that takes up to two days but
janscript solution allows the full
process to be completed and as short as
two hours with all the optimization we
keep the industry standard technology
with reliable results keep inventing
automated solutions to Safe labor and
time and generate consistent quality
if you find any of these content
interesting or would like to review the
webinar again please go to our website
to learn more or download the
comprehensive brochure on the website we
also have the demo videos of instruments
for you to check out
if you have any questions please feel
free to contact us through the email
here or go online to request for quote
we will be happy to assist you in your
research in the near future thank you